I went around the world for five weeks with just one razor.
Every day, I got ready to start something new.
This one taught me respect.
It's amazing and you can just tell like he's his master.
He just gives off this presence about him...
...that you really get to sense that...
...he knows what he's doing...
...and he takes what he's doing extremely serious.
I try not to expect anything, like, going into a situation like this.
I just try and gain a little perspective as to who he is...
...and why he does the things he does...
...and maybe learn something from that.
It's a very strict process,...
...him saying that it takes him about one month to complete a sword...
...which is unbelievable.
I mean, it's truly a craft; you start hitting it...
...and the smallest missed hit and it throws the entire shape off.
He had younger guys who were studying under him.
All these people work diligently...
...day in and day out for months to make that sword.
We kind of feel like that's a dying thing.
It's just so easy to go out and buy things,...
...and that there's something to be said about...
...working with your hands and going out and building something.
And when it's all finished, standing back and looking at it,...
...and be like, "Wow, I did that!"